I'm David I'm the supervising editor for
NPR visuals we're a team of
photographers designers developers who
support newsroom contents so we're tech
people all but our bosses our editors so
this is my contact information as my
team's contact information and this is
the URL for these slides and we're going
to be talking about scrapers today the
fascinating topic of scrapers and so yes
so do i want presenter view oh my gosh
no that's not what I want yeah yeah
copyright yeah yeah there we go ok cool
yeah whatever yeah not see another my
screen it's fine yeah yeah so go uh make
it small and then wherever your display
is yeah system preferences usually I
just have our print out region
arrangement and not mirror displays
there we go so basically you have to
write presenter view yet you have to
drag that over yeah there we go cool ok
there we go um ok so a real quick
trigger warning we're going to talk
about guns we're going to talk about
mass shootings I work in a newsroom we
talked about the dark stuff also i will
probably cuss so you know if if you're
uncomfortable with it this is your
chance to uh to take off arm and I'll
try not to
but I probably will so you know this
talk isn't actually so we're going to
talk about a straight at for NPR and
it's about the availability of guns in
the US and the way that we sort of got
answering some questions about the
availability of guns specifically on the
unregulated private market all is by
scraping a site called armslist com um
but this talk and the story the story
that we're going to talk about really
isn't whether gums are good or bad um
whether or not armslist calm is good or
bad it's really just a chance to sort of
answer a specific question that we have
about the world so I just want you to
keep that in mind that that's very much
kind of the journalist philosophy right
so we're going to be technical today um
and what I want to sort of emphasize
though is not so much the technology but
thinking like a day to journalists I
kind of hate getting technical um I'm
kind of trying to do my part to liberate
us from the iron cages of technologies
that we've created for selves and i have
a small budget and tight deadlines I
can't afford to screw around on
technical stuff for its own sake um if a
scraper can help me tell a story that
I'm in um but if scraper is really cool
but it doesn't tell me anything it's not
worth doing um and this this sort of
thinking is sort of the hallmark of data
journalism right so a lot of you
probably aren't journalists but I feel
like the skills that I have to use every
day are actually really broadly
applicable I have a sister who's in the
medical field she's got an MBA she does
business management and we were talking
a while ago and she was like wow I could
really use somebody who could normalize
and join some data from a bunch of
legacy systems um who could summarize
that data and then who could visualize
it and find some like squeeze in that
data that i can i can so i can
understand what's happening in my
business operation better as I hmm
sounds like you need a data journalist
so I think that these skills are in fact
really broadly applicable and and
what we're doing it has something to say
to kind of the wider world of data um so
let me tell you about this story I
worked on um so I did this with a
journalist named his name Raja and then
my team members Juan Brittany and Alison
um and it's about the availability of
guns in the unregulated private market
um we did this in response to the mass
shooting in orlando where it seemed that
the the shooter may have indeed
purchased the gun on one of these online
marketplaces but we're also just curious
like how how hard is it in orlando to
like get an ar-15 on a tight timeline um
and so and so his name had been a
journalist a mother jones have covered
mass shootings in it extensively has
sort of built up kind of one of the key
databases in the country about about
that phenomena because nobody there's no
official tracking of that so it's sort
of left independent actors to track that
arm and and i was interested in sort of
sort of the mechanics of getting a gun
online like if I want to get a gun
around Orlando like what does that mean
and so I was digging around and I found
this site armslist calm and you know was
seeing these listings that were really
interesting so I thought maybe this this
could some be something that we can
scrape and so I'm going to talk a little
bit about the thought process that went
into deciding it was something that we
could scrape and then we'll talk a
little bit about the actual architecture
that cloud architecture we use the way
we organize your code and all that good
stuff um and again this isn't about
armslist.com per se it's more it's more
about this sort of general question then
we use the scraper to help us answer it
we release find some preliminary answers
so this is part of the piece this is a
map of the United States and the bubbles
represent the number of listings on
armslist calm and the period that we
looked and there's some interesting
stuff in here we don't go deeply into it
in the piece because we didn't want to
speculate but one thing that you'll see
there is
reno nevada arm which isn't labeled
unfortunately but Reno Nevada is a tiny
city it's it's 225,000 people and yet
there's a big bubble on Reno Nevada um
and you know it's sort of funny it's
like well you've got this small city but
it's next to a state with restrictive
gun control laws home and you can sort
of see the ironies of the the current
state by state state system right there
on that border and you see some other
interesting things in the in the
geographic view too so um check out
oklahoma city oklahoma city is not a big
city clearly there's a lot of guns being
sold at least I armslist.com their arm
but Oklahoma City is that is at the
intersection of interstate 35 and
interstate 44 which are two of the most
important drug rats in the United States
um it's also to the most important
routes for your iPhone's for potatoes
these are major transit arteries and so
it's actually no surprise in some ways
that a place that is heavily trafficked
for all kinds of things would also be a
place where guns are being bought and
sold more in a disproportionate amount
to the population um and so I'm kind of
interested in that question that's
something that we'd like to follow up on
arm when you see it again when you look
at the number of listings by state um
and you'll see that Ohio North Carolina
Oklahoma of Florida are the top four arm
and it's probably no surprise but Ohio
is one of the most traffic states
relative to the population of the state
in the country armed and very gun-happy
states like Wyoming and Montana are
actually represented very low on here in
absolute numbers but even when we were
doing the analysis even in population
adjusted numbers um even though they are
states with lots of guns they're not a
lot of people in those states
necessarily selling or trading guns on
the private market so we found some
interesting stuff with this with this
scraper um so this is a this is a quote
that ends ends the piece much has been
made of the fact that Orlando shooter
and we're mateen who purchased both of
the weapons to use them as deadly
rampage legally was twice investigated
by the FBI for suspected terrorist ties
um but he didn't end up on the terrorist
watch list even if you had mateen still
it could have legally purchased his guns
terrorism suspects are not prohibited
from owning firearms now some typically
on the opposite side of gun control
debate are pushing to change that but
even if mateen were on the watch list
and even if known terrorists were barred
from purchasing weapons from licensed
dealers unregulated private sales made
easier through online marketplaces like
armslist still kind of enabled him to
buy the less there to buy the weapons so
this is really sort of the central
thesis of our piece all right so let's
talk about planning to scrape now that
we've talked a little bit about the
background of the story arm and this is
this is I think kind of the really key
point so people get excited right let's
make a scraper it's a popular first
programming exercise it's a popular
first data journalism exercise um it
seems like a cool sort of simple thing
to do but I want you to ask yourself do
I need a scraper um they're awesome if
you use them right um they're really
really powerful but you need to know
what they're good for and what it takes
to do them right um because they're not
so simple it turns out um so the first
thing so the thing to know about
scrapers really is that if you need a
scraper you have a data problem um so
something's not right in the world
there's a database out there somewhere
that's powering a website right arm but
you don't have access to the database
you only have access to the website um
now if you're working in sort of
journalism or with government that means
that like somebody's dropping the ball
in terms of being able to provide public
data um because if it's on a public
website this is the underlying structure
data probably should also be public um
or if it's in your company it means that
you know whatever like the old guys then
in the basement like you know just they
just aren't going to get with the times
and you're going to have to deal with
some crappy old legacy database right
you know the good data is so so so yeah
so so scraper means you have a data
problem but like the good data you know
the good data it's if it was if it was
if it was you know if it wasn't the good
data um it wouldn't be hard to get the
good stuffs a lot of times hard to get
and so that's why scrapers are often
worth it but you know data problems are
a fact of life and oftentimes for
totally understandable reasons so I
actually had to scrape my own
organization's website to figure out
where stories were being placed on the
homepage on a minute-by-minute basis um
because the history isn't stored in the
content management system that totally
makes sense because when they built the
content management system eight years
ago well I mean you maybe wouldn't even
do it today it's just a lot of data to
keep around for not necessarily a lot of
gain um until somebody decides they
wanted and out so i got my gosh what do
we do um so yeah so uh so I've often a
lot of the scraping that I've done is
often of some internal resource whether
it was when I was working at Fermilab a
national science lab and we had to
scrape sites because we didn't want to
FOIA other departments because that's
how we got data from other departments
home so we just would scrape stuff I've
had to scrape vendor websites when I
worked at the Chicago Tribune because we
didn't have access to an API or an
underlying data source Oh a lot of the
scraping I've done has never actually
been seen by the public it's for
internal use um and a lot of times you
don't get good data about that out of it
um so we'll talk about that in a second
but here's a couple things that you need
to do and I say this just listen because
I say this is somebody who's made like
every one of these mistakes um don't
scrape unless there is no other way of
liberating the data like make a phone
call first leg hey can I have your data
um it helps a budget appropriately
scrapers are not free they may not cost
a lot they may seem simple on the
surface but we are talking about things
that are like all edge cases um they're
pure
edge cases and these things you can do
to make that easier which is what we'll
talk about in a minute but but
ultimately like their pain to test if
there's always going to be little things
that you don't anticipate when you
scrape 80,000 URLs and he's only looked
at plenty or even a hundred of them all
manually you should consider the ethical
ramifications of scraping so one scraper
project I did was concerning Cook County
Jail arm today and an inmate locator and
so we scraped it about about how long
people stayed had what charges they were
coming in on on race we even had height
and weight and end date of birth which
we turn into age so that we wouldn't
have too much identifying information
and in this little API we created out of
it it was funny because other
departments and in the city of Chicago
used our teta to make sure that the
Sheriff's Department wasn't giving them
bad numbers every month um which was
interesting but one thing that was
really like I I regret is that we took
down the site um we built a little too
high powered of a scraper we ran too
many parallel scrapes at once we were
not the only people doing it it turned
out that that there was a bigger problem
with these like background check sites
that were scraping jail inmate data and
that's screwed up right because jail is
not where you go when you're convicted
jail is where you go before you get
convicted um and innocent until proven
guilty and all that stuff right um so
these background checks websites were
pulling up jail data on without actually
any knowledge of whether or not the
person was was in fact convicted of the
crime of which they were charged in all
events we brought that on this website
arm doesn't seem like a big deal like
well the government you know couldn't
keep their [ __ ] up right Oh home but
this is what public defenders use to
know how to get in touch with their
clients this is what people use to be
able to visit their cousin or their
brother or their on or their uncle oh
well if you're stuck in a jail that that
people stand often for 69 months a year
um so you have to consider the ethical
ramifications
shins um don't take people's stuff off
on all and we'll talk a little bit about
how you can deal with that the happy end
of that story is that we worked with the
Sheriff's Department they blocked they
blocked the other scrapers and a ladders
to continue all you need to read the
Terms of Service of the site you're
reading and you need to do your legal
research and if you're doing this for a
company or even in an independent
project you should talk to a lawyer um
if you're doing this for a publication
or for a company you absolutely need to
talk to cancel um I don't I think it's
not optional um you know I think if
you're doing it independently you just
need to be really careful the key thing
to look for in the Terms of Service is a
prohibition against digital copying arm
so while you cannot copyright a fact and
CNN com for example is full of tables of
facts that reasonably you could scrape
their terms of service prohibits digital
copying all and so that means that
scraping CNN com is in fact a legal gray
area if not illegal um so you want to be
careful about stuff like that um and
then you want to ask yourself can you
scrape you want to be sort of a console
and curl detective and we'll talk about
that in a second but you want to look
what is the URL structure what is the
the Dom structure of the pigs you're
trying to scrape um and what kind of
servers on the other end um so here's
the due diligence we did for the
armslist piece there was no better data
source there's no data source in fact
they know he's tracking this nationally
um so you actually have to get it from
the vendors from the marketplaces um
there's a very predictable URL structure
is very easy to get data out of the out
of their listing system um while this
while the pages themselves sort of make
a mockery of bootstrap driven design
things were pretty consistent it was
pretty easy to pull data out of the
pages um turned out that they had a
gleefully libertarian terms of service
um the people who run this site wanted
nothing to do with the underlying
content on the site disclaim themselves
of all responsibility and had no
prohibition against copying um and so
they
was an easy one I took it was an easy
one for me to see like this is probably
something we can do and it was an easy
one for the lawyer to read through it
and say like yep check check check like
none of this pertain to us we can scrape
this site um and then it turned out that
the the servers that armslist were on it
was running were fast they seem to be
robust um when I sniff around the
response headers there are no weird
smells everything seemed cool on that
front so let's take a look at that um so
it looks so this is what i did with curl
arm curl minus i just shows you the
headers for URL um and minus w lets you
let's curl print out certain variables
about like what happened um specifically
response times transfer time request
start time all that kind of stuff um so
this looks pretty good so you know it's
a relatively up-to-date version of i is
all they seem to have cache control
headers uh you know it just seems like a
pretty modern server so that's cool um
and the response time was blisteringly
fast this is just on my internet
yesterday all yesterday morning just on
my my cable at home um and this thing
came back really fast so that's good so
alright their servers pretty solid looks
like people another and know what
they're doing um and then i would say so
i did that and then I was a sort of a
dom detective so it's hard to see but
you can see at the top in the URL bar
just take my word for it the URLs are
pretty well structured all then you can
see i got i open up my console and I'm
moving my mouse ran and it turns out
that the only h1 on the page forgiven
listing is the title on for sale trade
in this case towards 38 special all it
turned out that the HTML was relatively
well format it is pretty easy to
identify unique elements on the page
that we could extract the data that
we're looking for from and and just to
go into a little more detail on this
page so we want to pull out its you know
where as we're doing this
like well what do we want to pull out
arm and you know at minimum what we're
looking for is is title on some sort of
categorization so this was listed in
handguns it could have been listed in
rifles ammunition things of that nature
um so we wanted yes so title category
price excuse me mm location um we're
kind of key things and then of course
the date that the listing had actually
been posted all so yeah so those are the
sorts of things that we're trying to
find like how hard is it going to be
just to use basic Dom manipulations and
get the stuff out of the page and it's
like okay well not not too crazy um
here's the terms of service if the long
terms of service and it's interesting
because they don't bury this terms of
service it's actually click wrap on the
site um so you know you're really you
don't have to fish around you know
exactly what you're working with when
wouldn't dealing with this site which is
which is good from the standpoint of
what we're doing so uh scrapers what are
they good for um they're actually pretty
good for understanding and information
system or an underlying data model I
feel like a lot of what I've learned
doing scrapers especially government
websites is not so much getting the data
but figuring out how the underlying
system works um so for example cook
cannock jail uses an old flat file
database from its we're still running on
like I'm like a mini computer arm to
track inmates and so they don't have a
history of where people stayed when they
were in the jail they just have a field
that gets replaced every time somebody
moves um and then there was something
that we were able to sort of see by
repeatedly scraping the site arm so you
learn a little bit about the actual
system that you're dealing with ah it's
good for pressuring institutions to
release data scrapers are really good
political tools if you're an activist or
even if you're journalist um we're just
somebody who's trying to make change in
your company um a lot of times people
are like manage tried to release that
data that's scary you know there's the
data is dirty we could get in trouble
like you know this oftentimes p
who have valid reasons to not make their
data public but its data that should be
public oh and once you start scraping it
and like the world doesn't collapse on
them um they'll be a little more
interested in in maybe opening it up for
you oh it can really actually open doors
and create pressure to sort of get
better data um and of course it's
getting its good at liberating data into
structured formats um but then there's a
question about the quality of that data
occasionally you're going to get good
data out of it with arms list we got
pretty lucky and we were able to get
really good data um but that's not often
the case so oftentimes your your
experiment will end and you learning a
lot and um getting something useful but
the actual data you get is going to be
maybe a little iffy arm when scrapers
will require resources so developments
the easy part uh testings the hard part
like I said they're all educators right
like you're scraping 80,000 URLs and on
4040 45,000 202 a new Dom element pops
into the list things that you didn't
expect and now you've lost half your
prices um or something like that so so
there are all edge cases you can't
predict the future right you can do
stuff to test the end understand better
on what you're working with but you're
only ever going to know if it's going to
work once you test it with a full corpus
of data um and that takes time and
infrastructure is another is another
issue uh scrapers don't cost nothing to
run arm we're going to talk about how
much it cost us it didn't cost much a
couple dollars um but imagine if you're
doing this scrape every single day
there's a couple dollars add up and do
you know but not zero um it actually
cost some money oh and if you're running
your scraper periodically running it
over time um you need to maintain that
things so that Cook County Jail scrapers
lovely as a project it was I got tired
of paying for the Amazon bill out of
pocket which was twenty bucks a month um
and it kept breaking and I didn't know
why and I didn't
time to fix it so I just had no moth
wallet um maybe I ran for three years so
it's not a bad run but in all events uh
any questions at this point everybody
seems very quiet today yes
earlier you do they just are they useful
any standard rendering yes if it's
interesting so uh yes that happens um
one place where I saw it was was dealing
with Cook County didn't cook county they
had a whole bunch of it old asp servers
and they all basically had the same HTML
structure um it was all positional so
like nothing had IDs or classes or
anything that identified it um but there
was actually a surprise and consistency
between their warrant lookup system the
inmate locator there was another one
that we were scraping at the same time
um and we actually wrote kind of a
common parser er um because you could
you could abstract enough parts of it
that uh dad wait maybe i don't know i
mean it I'm certainly I imagined similar
yeah I don't know it's a good question
its case by case in that case I think
like you you know you might get lucky if
you're trying to scrape three different
WordPress sites and lo and behold
they're all using modified versions of
the same theme um but you might not yeah
so are the are there certain sites or
classifications of sites that are you
know okay on that like I'm guessing like
government data is probably public and
you said that like being kind of like
public records like I'm guessing
lifetime cues
yeah that's a good question too so
there's some states that have tried to
copyright government data um I don't
know what the status of it is at this
point um the eff has been tracking it
there's a couple of states that are
trying to do that I wouldn't be
absolutely it is not a guarantee that
government data is in fact legal to
scrape um it should be probably most of
the time if it is public facing on the
internet and provided by the government
that would be my humble opinion about
that arm but uh but you should always
you should always read the Terms of
Service you should always check with a
lawyer the case law as far as I
understand is is is complicated and
there's not a fully fully comprehensive
view of this you can scrape this yeah
you can definitely skip this
right yeah yeah yeah so that's that's
one of the things we're going to talk
about I mean that's what we did we
basically with the Cook County Jail
scraper we inadvertently participated in
what amounted to DDoS right these
background check sites and our scraper
were all hammering this poured by 486
and in like the bowels of some data
center underneath a garage in Chicago um
and and we took it down and it really
was a DDoS because it was multiple
parties who were trying to scrape the
site um we got lucky but we one of the
things we learned from that is we should
have just called the sheriff's
department they were happy to have us
running the scraper um they wanted the
data too because well because their
system contract we're like one of the
burning questions the cook county jail
is like how many times does a person
move and their underlying data system
could not track that and our system
could so um so their their metrics
people were like yeah keep scraping whoo
this is cool so so yeah so so but we
should have called them first we should
just found out and you know I mean for
the most part if it is public government
data like you should be able to get
ahold of that but that's also why you
should FOIA first that's why you should
call first arm you should always make
sure you can get this data in another
way um cool so yes so let's talk a
little bit about scraper architecture
we'll talk about data models tests um
actually we won't talk about tests today
sir we're not going to have time um and
I didn't get a chance to write them home
but we'll talk about how you would do it
I can show you some other tests but if
you want to talk about tests atomic
request parallelization in the clan
infrastructure we used um and some of
you now if you're big geeks are probably
like whoa what about scrapey scrapey is
awesome
what about mechanized mechanized is
awesome there's all these tools that
help you do exactly what we're talking
about um and the reason why well there's
a couple things um a couple of reasons
why i'm not going to show you scraping
your mechanized or tools like that um
fundamentally is that is that we are
framework nihilists on my team oh we
like the fundamentals we like to build
things from simple tools that we
understand what they do um we're a
little lazy so if we don't have to learn
a new framework we don't um and
hopefully by talking about some of these
more underlying issues you'll understand
that why scrapy is built the way it does
because one thing that I hear from folks
actually after I published a blog post
arm which all I had the link to this
presentation about that basically is
covering the same material arm a data
journalist buddy of mine was like but I
still don't understand why I want to use
encapsulate my data models and classes
he's like scrapy makes me do that and I
don't understand that and so hopefully
we can talk a little bit about why um by
looking at these kind of lower level
choices and why they're important arm so
let's talk a little bit about the
workflow of the scraper that we used um
you basically start this process by
running a controller script arm that
harvests listing URLs from the
armslist.com search listing index arm
and then it takes that same list of URLs
and then launches the scraper scripts
which go out and in parallel scrape and
and bring back data from the actual
listings on armslist com so it's a
standard model right there's a page that
you click through to see the details of
individual listings that page has
pagination you can harvest urls from
that and then scrape each individual
listing page um so yeah so the thing
that we're going to do here though is
what i call the drake principle so we
start with the controller script it
calls the index scraper which then
harvests these URLs which then in turn
calls the listing scraper which goes out
and scrapes the the individual listings
for weapons for sale arm and and and so
yeah so the the Drake principle of
programming is that you have to start at
the bottom um Wow crickets my my intern
thought it was really funny um we start
at the bottom never here anyway we're
going to be up at the top eventually um
so but we're going to start with and fan
it will take a look at the controller
script but then what we're going to
start with is actually how we
encapsulate the data and work our way up
to the to the full process so this is
the script it's a little hard this heads
kind of maybe a little hard to see um
but basically it's a pretty simple
controller script it spits out a list of
the saints arm pipes that to the
parallel command we'll talk about that
later on basically what that does is it
creates a bunch of scrapers that go out
and scrape however many states at a time
um from the data and it's just a way to
segment segment the scraper so it runs a
little faster that part's not nearly as
optimized as the thing that actually
goes out and scrapes the listings um
because there are so many guns being
posted on on armslist calm at a given
moment all even paginate enthral aquella
RLS because stuffs being pushed into the
top so if you get a page to a list thing
that was on page one is now on page two
um we figured it was a couple thousand
an hour i think you're getting listed um
so it's it's it's pretty active um which
causes some problems I'll tell you about
it gotcha we realized that there was a
better way to do it later um but we had
four days to do the project so so we did
what we could um and then on that last
line this is what we're going to dive
into first we're taking this this list
of
index pages it's a CSV it's got some
extra detail about the pages so you're
using CSV kit is this handy library that
helps you manipulate CSVs um we're
cutting just the first the first column
um to get a list of URLs and then we're
passing that again into new parallel to
scrape the listings and so it's gonna
guy and it's going to scrape some
listings whoa okay um is every reason
over you with me okay people are
following that's good um cool so let's
talk a little bit about the model class
that underlies this whole thing so one
of the things that I found is is most
helpful in writing scrapers is basically
to take a chunk of HTML and pass it into
a class that hides all the parsing arm
so that you get an interface out that
looks exactly like the data that you
want to see arm so let's actually just
take a look sorry um so the input is
HTML or text that we want to parse that
we want to scrape stuff out of um we
want to class interface that looks like
our output so if we have date of birth
in the in the underlying data um but
what we want is age we create a data
model where you say data model dot age
and it calculates the age based on the
date of birth it hides that complexity
away so that anything that's that's
dealing with this data model doesn't
need to know anything about how screwed
up the underlying the underlying page
was that feta um and so you can so so
that way you can hike calculations hi
joining and splitting fields you can
basically hide away all the complexity
arm so let's take a look at this this is
where i really wish i could get up and
kind of jump around um oh maybe I can
does this thing um okay so so if we take
a look at the init function for this
class so this encapsulate SAS engl gun
listing this is this is this is a
gun that's for sale on armslist com all
and you'll see that our initialization
method takes one takes one parameter and
that's HTML so so our model doesn't care
whether that HTML came from the network
whether it came from an automated pest
um whether it came from the command line
from standard in it doesn't care it just
needs HTML um and then you'll see that
we use and so they say there's a little
frontmatter we're using beautifulsoup to
do the parsing there's other stuff that
works pretty well as well pi query um is
another library to do this if you're
feeling masochistic and we're can read
German documentation lxml is good Alex
ml is actually amazing but it's just
really obtuse um it's not necessarily
super familiar to people who are used to
working with that kind of node level Dom
level kind of kind of interface um so
because we want to be you know we want
our intern to be able to work on it
right we we use things like beautiful
soup we do we want to write code it's
sort of an 8th grade reading level arm
because we feel like that helps it just
helps adoption and it helps our team
collaborate more effectively um so we
try not to do too many fancy things um
so yeah so there's a little bit in the
init function beyond that arm but the
key action is is let's take a look at
line 10 through 12 arm so we use that
property decorator anybody know what the
property decorator is it's it sets its
getter setter for a python class so
instead of dot title parentheses a
method call on the object all you just
say got titles where you say dot title
equals um so property basically turns a
method into what behaves like a property
once you access the the class interface
or an instance in ER patients i should
say um so the title one's very simple in
this case um we get the beautiful soup
object and we find that h1 in
side of it because what we found is that
there's only h11 h1 tag on every listing
page and it is the title that the seller
typed in um course 38 for sale middle
Illinois whatever um now on lines 14
through 22 you'll see a little more
complicated one we have even more
complicated ones in this in this file
arm but this is a nice one so sometimes
the price starts with a dollar sign and
sometimes it doesn't oh I don't know why
it must be something about typing in the
how do you type in the price maybe maybe
you're just a lab to type a dollar sign
or not um and so we check to see if it
starts with a dollar sign jettison the
dollar sign if it does or just pass
through the string so this is an example
of hiding that complexity right you want
price you want price to be priced to be
price to be expressed the same way every
time when you're accessing the data and
by encapsulating as these parsing
methods of an instance of this theta
model um you get this very nice sort of
interface um and then you can do fancy
things with it because that property
decorator those those those properties
it acts truly like properties so when
you have a model instance you can call
[ __ ] on it and get a dictionary of all
those all those properties so you can
use all this fancy kind of Python all
this kind of fancy Python meta
programming stuff um which is you know
maybe a little helpful see anybody gave
questions at this point is this model
return bad you might answer sir if your
indexer has ten URLs and you only get
nine back because something's wrong here
this very sort of detection that things
like if you got a price that was money
signs 50 space you're not going to get
that yeah so it turned out that we
didn't need too much exception handling
but basically we do that one step up so
the model class is supposed so actually
if something breaks like that you want
it to break right you don't want that
you don't want
bad data sneaking in su so if this price
thing were to break I'd want an
exception to be raised than to stop and
to see why the world wasn't as I
expected it to be right um so basically
we we step up one level um they actually
do the actual scraping so we'll take a
look at that right now um so let's take
a look at the listing scraper file which
takes this data model all and calls it
and there's a some kind of so this is
this is what makes the magic happen
basically so in addition to having this
data model where we can encapsulate a
listing um we have a scraper script very
simple thing um I I would have loved to
show you the whole thing because it's
only a few more lines than this but uh
but it would be hard to read otherwise
um and in the scrape listing function
takes a URL it creates a listing object
out of that URL and then just spits out
basically a CSV output to the console
arm and one thing that we could have
done it may very well may have been
smart would have been to wrap that bit
from line 15 the line 22 in a try except
to capture any errors if we ran in
deniers and maybe log those um it turned
out that this was such a simple scraping
job in a lot of ways that we didn't have
to um but we got lucky in some sense in
the end might have wanted to do that but
but I would put that at that level um
not at the level of your model um your
model should break when the data isn't
what you expect that's good right
because because because now you know
that there's going to be that you have a
new edge case to contend with and we ran
into some kind of funny edgy cases like
every state you could you can get
listings by state every state uses the
standard abbreviation except for New
Jersey in South Florida which is not a
state um so if you look in this code
you'll see when it returns state there's
an exception that says if it's South
Florida return Florida um for some
reason
there's so many guns in fact being sold
in Florida I guess that armslist has
decided to consider it two different
states um and then there's the index
scraper which harvests the index URLs
we're going to skip that one because
it's actually basically exactly what I
just described um but you can take a
look at the code we can talk about it
later and then last but not least let's
talk again about this controller script
arm and specifically about ganute
parallel because this is really a handy
tool um so anybody done multiprocessing
parallelization and Python I've seen
some hands is it the most fun thing no
it's not fun at all you can do it and
it's pretty cool but again I feel like
like I want my Python code to be
something that like an intern can jump
into and just be immediately productive
and if I've got like job live calls all
over the place and like trying to
parallel lies like loops and
asynchronous things are happening like
forget about it like it's impossible to
read so let's put that parallelization
actually up one level like that put this
at the level of actually calling um any
of actually scraping a single listing
and parallel eyes that and let me just
go back for a second um so this is
really crucial to because I can just
once if I want to test this thing I can
run scrape listing that py and get the
output of a single URL so it's very easy
for me to test this scraper in this way
I can show you but I think we're gonna
run out of time um yes so good new
parallel is really handy canoe parallel
basically says I take some input like
cata file a list of URLs and then you
call the command that you're going to
call with parallel in front and then
curly braces as this as the argument
substitution and all of a sudden you
have parallel processing um it
automatically detects how many cores
your system has you can overload it you
can under load it whatever you want to
do um it's a really really handy tool
it's mainly used by academics and so
that's why the world doesn't
no more about it it doesn't it just
keeps running yeah just keeps running um
which could actually have its
disadvantages if you saw something
breaking you but but it also also
responds the standard like console
signals control C will stop it you don't
have weird processes hanging around it's
really really cool so that's basically
what's happening in line 11 arm we're
getting a list of URLs and passing
passing that two parallel which is
calling scrape listing that py and then
the curly braces represent each URL
that's getting passed then um so so
imagine the CSV cut is basically just
just a list of URLs that's all it is
right and it's being piped to parallel
which is then substituting each URL for
scrape listing pi and parallels figuring
out how to optimally parallel eyes this
process on your on your computer um and
we'll talk a little bit about the
infrastructure because it's helpful to
know just how handy it is to do this
parallelization um we we use amazon EC 3
I think cloud services in general or
very good way to go when you're doing
scraping like this all and we fired up
with is actually a fairly expensive
server ac3 8 x large that's a 16-core
machine all if i recall correctly uh
it's it's 16 or 32 it's big oh it's
quote-unquote compute optimized we
didn't have one specific bottleneck we
weren't like blowing up memory we were
blowing up processor but the thing it
was most intensive was processor so we
gotta compute optimized instance rather
than say like a storage optimized
instance all in all that we were able to
scrape about 80,000 URLs in about 16
minutes so not bad um and then included
the less than optimal harvester of URLs
so it was it was pretty fast um
but it's always important to remember
not to accidentally create a denial of
service attack I should note that that
60 minutes scrape meant about 50 cents
of scrape but remember to turn off your
ec2 instance with when you're done with
it you don't have to terminate it you
can keep it ready to like fire up again
um but you're charged for every minute
that it's on so you can save a lot of
money if you like fire this thing up
spin it up run it for you know as long
as you need to run at 16 minutes all
these you can imagine like fifty cents
every 15 minutes actually isn't cheap um
if you're accidentally run this thing
24-7 so there's two things that you
should do you should put a header on
your request that identifies yourself um
it's bath achill thing to do um it's if
you're journalist you absolutely should
do it because I because we're supposed
to identify ourselves right oh if I'm
interviewing a subject I can't lie about
Who I am all man we feel like that
principle should apply to scrapers that
we're writing as well as interviews that
we're doing of sources right all and
then and then yeah so let me go to the
next next slide because it speaks to
exactly what you're talking that you
should proceed with care in terms of
slamming another server um it's hard to
know what level of traffic will will
knock out a server um you should
increase your number of parallel request
incrementally if you notice any kind of
slow down or hiccup back off like chill
Oh home it's better to throttle and put
in some like one-second weights or half
second weights arm or send less less
concurrent requests um and accept that
that you're just going to have to be
patient getting your data than any other
alternative right oh you don't want to
get sued you don't want to get in
trouble oh you want to be a good citizen
so you want to be careful about that but
the tricky thing is
is unless you actually call the folks
and sometimes you can't um we did try to
call our most armslist but they didn't
call us back um you know you uh you
don't know you know you you honestly
don't know what's going to take them out
um but we did a little background and
what a world we live a little background
research so what a world we live in um
we put the late capitalist technical
infrastructure monopoly to work on our
behalf so it turned out that we use
Amazon ec2 drums that armslist uses
amazon ec2 and so we're actually able to
put our scraper in the same data center
that they were in and get a lightning
fast Network response times um and we
increment Lee increase the number of
parallel scrapes we realized that we
could use a very big server and cause
them no trouble arm and so so we use
something quite optimized um but you
know if if it wouldn't have been the
case we would have just slowed down it
didn't matter that much um oh yeah so uh
we use the max mine geoip there's a
couple IP tools that will let you do
this maximum mind is like an IP
geolocation service um really helpful
it's how we figure out that you live in
Nebraska so so we can show at NPR so
that we can show you how much your local
school district sponge per pupil things
like that um but then you have a little
demo site you can put in some URLs and
you're put in some IPS and find out
where they are in the world all we did
that anyway because we're like well
let's pick a datacenter if this is on
the west coast let's pick a data center
on the west coast um if it's in Asia
let's pick the data center in Singapore
right oh so we just want to know where
we wanted to put our server and when we
did there were when we did the max mine
geoip look up we were like oh we can put
it in the same data center um so yeah so
that was a little sneaky bit of a coat
or a little sneaky bit of detective work
on in our case in all events we've only
got a couple minutes
so just to finish up we publish the CSV
with the story we documented the code
and then there's actually a couple to
do's on our end all we want to write
tests we should have written tests but
we only had four days um and but at
least through the the model interface we
can we could just stick some HTML into
the into the model class and like see if
it works the way we expect all we
realized that we could have used the
incremental IDs that it's just that
counter on armslist com their IDs are
just the counter and so there was
probably some optimization we could have
done around using that URL pattern to
our advantage and then there was just
other analysis we wanted to do in our
story that we didn't get to UM all right
so we only have five minutes I think
does anybody have any quick questions oh
I didn't know there's a break in between
I'm sorry okay come talk to me thank you